on what kind of odds would you risk the
future of mankind
at this point you know about 14,000 what
we call near-earth asteroids
there were impacts in the past there
will definitely be impact in the future
the question is when and will we be
ready
I work for a solar system dynamics
driven JPL we're kind of the flight
control for the solar system anything
that moves we want to know the orbital
comets from near-earth asteroids
main-belt asteroids planets satellites
comets so it really is a true kind of
traffic center my first memory of really
being interested in space was a lot of
okay let me start rambling and then guys
will care you know when I was a child I
can't say that the meaning of the
universe was very important to me my
first memory of being intrigued by space
was when Carl Sagan's Cosmos was a TV
Carl Sagan was such a kind of natural
talent to talk about these mysteries of
the universe and you understand the
basic concepts but then also you know
that's at the same time inspired me
because I wanted to understand much more
I wanted to understand the details
so there is a very large reservoir of
asteroids that are between the orbits of
Mars and Jupiter you probably have
billions of objects there so what
happens is that because of the great
Asian influence of Jupiter and Saturn
some of these objects get kind of nudged
and they migrate into the inner solar
system and that is what we call
near-earth objects discovering
near-earth objects it's very important
because they have changed the history of
the earth there are many many large
impacts in Earth's history
asteroids definitely brought some
organic material the question is whether
they brought water
we know that asteroids affected life on
Earth 66 million years ago a very large
asteroid about ten kilometers in
diameter hit on Yucatan Peninsula in
Mexico to the best of our knowledge
besides immediate obliteration in the
radius of hundreds of kilometers the
impact kicked out enough dust that the
earth would be engulfed in darkness for
several years and that could have been
the main cause of the extinction of 75%
of species on earth including the
dinosaurs so this is something very
profound for us it's kind of our
responsibility as a species to
understand the risk involved the way
that you discover a near-earth asteroids
is with large telescopes there was a
mandate by Congress for NASA to discover
all the near-earth asteroids they're
larger than one kilometer and by now we
know about 95% of these objects but that
is not going to be enough because
something sighs of probably 50 meters
can cause like a city level devastation
there are millions of these objects and
we can only guess that we maybe know
maybe a percent I mean we got hit just
in 2013
chelebi's was a demonstration of what a
small asteroid can do it was not even
something that reached the surface
so you see how even these smaller ones
can still potentially be dangerous if we
find something with some chance of
impact we would probably have at least
several years to prepare so in that case
there would probably be a deflection
mission that musically means that you
have a spacecraft that kind of rams into
an asteroid and changes its velocity and
you end up completely missing the earth
we did have a little mini trial there
was a spacecraft called deep impact that
rammed into comet Tempel
this is not a science fiction asteroids
larger than 30 meters impact earth about
once every few centuries larger than 300
meters once every hundred thousand years
so it is very wise to keep a watch
we have born curious we are all born
explorers and we just kind of started
looking out and really understanding
what is their place in the solar system
you try to understand the small things
and then hopefully during your career
you're going to work on much more
complex projects that really can address
some of the fundamental questions of the
universe my real love is there's
somebody out there